[Applaudissements]
au talon mais moi j'aimerais bien
l'avoir dans un autre style d'émission
et moi je pense que je la connais très
bien ce ne sont pas que c'est moi
j'attends de lui céder seul c'est la
seule émission sur la tête de manière
dont je vous parle presque il ya des
gars nous gala c'est la seule émission
il ya des cadreurs vous faire regarder
ce qu'il fait mais je vais le montrer
parce que l'art et je vais montrer le
gars a mis en garde ce qu'il fait mais
comme ça tant il est comme ça et comment
on est la seule émission où les cadors
il va se casser mon frère je crois sur
tmc dans un documentaire frérot est
inquiète pas d'indépendants envie de te
voir si beau bébé
alors oui et vous disais vous appuyez
déjà moi j'ai dit qu'elle était hyper
talentueuse et que j'aimerais bien
l'avoir dans son nouveau concept
d'émission signifie qu un coeur gros
comme ça et moi je voudrais avoir dans
une émission où elle aiderait des gens
des adolescents notamment en difficulté
c'était un peu le constater victoire
bonnot et je pense qu'elle pourrait
faire une émission les bredele
d'occupation double
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à l'aube de voir et me plaît ou ça on
fait assez rarement ça la maison mais
effectuer nos pêches